BEN FRIED: Good afternoon.
Who cares about
new domain names?
The short answer is
we think you should.
And we certainly do,
too And actually, this
is the most
important, and I think
an exciting change, in the
internet in a long, long time,
maybe since the beginning
of the modern internet
as we knew it, at least as
users will experience it.
And we are incredibly
excited about this.
And if that is not enough, if
our excitement and the changes
in the internet aren't
enough to get you excited,
we're going to give each
and every one of you
a free domain name
registration to use soon,
as part of our new domain
registrar business.
So hang on till the end
to learn more about that.
I hope that that
helps excite you
about the topic a little bit.
Yay!
Free!
Free is good!
Domain names actually cost more
than t-shirts, even in bulk.
So you're getting a good deal.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
I'm Ben.
Ben Fried.
I'm Google's chief
information officer.
I'll be joined on stage later
by Kripa, and during the Q&A,
Corey's going to come
and join us as well.
So just out of curiosity, how
many of you manage a domain,
have a domain under management?
Oh, all right, awesome.
How many manage more
than 10 domains?
How many of you
manage more than 50?
You're an impressive bunch.
You certainly
out-domain manage me.
OK.
And so you're clearly experts.
So this is material that
you didn't need to hear,
but just to set expectations
for the broader audience, what's
in a name.
Obviously, names are locations.
They're how we find
things on the internet.
They're what make the
web nameable and usable.
They're incredibly important.
The key components
that we're going
to be talking about in
names are that stuff
to the right of the last dot
is called the top-level domain.
.com is an example of what's
called a generic top-level
domain.
There are also country code
top-level domains, like .us,
for example.
Google is the second
level domain here.
Obviously in the site
name, google.com.
Keep those terms in mind if
you didn't already know them.
It's very important.
So why are we talking
about domain names?
Why do we care about them?
What makes them
important in our lives?
And the answer is
that domain names
are the key to making
the internet work for us.
What's important about names is
that they need to be readable.
You need to understand the
location, address of the place
that you want to go.
Domain names also
need to be memorable.
It does you no good to
have a location or a place
that you want to go if you
can't remember it in the future.
And finally, names, as
in all things in life,
names work best when they're
meaningful to us and actually
kind of convey something
that's important to us.
But it's no secret to
this group of experts
that as the internet
has matured,
something has happened to names.
Finding meaningful names
has become a lot harder.
And when I try to explain
this to friends and family,
I go to that oracle of the
internet, Jack Donaghy,
the character played by
Alec Baldwin in "30 Rock."
And here's a quote from the
television show "30 Rock."
"I just registered the domain
name for my campaign website.
Jackdonaghyisrunningformayor2013newyorkthisisthewebsite.com.
That's as close as I could get.
Everything else was
already pornography."
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
So how did we get here?
How did we get to the point
where a broadcast prime time
comedy can actually
be telling us
something we all relate to
about the exhaustion of names
on the internet?
You actually have to go back
and put this in context.
In 1985, when the modern
internet naming was created,
there were seven
top-level domains.
And in fact, the very first name
registered, which was in .com,
was symbolics.com, which was
owned by the Symbolics Computer
Corporation.
But over the next,
I guess 29 years,
we've seen over 240 million
domain names registered
in the second-level
domain space.
And the result is the
situation that Jack described.
To give you more
color on it, and I
think this is probably
obvious to all of you.
Of the almost 460,000 four
letter .com domain names that
are possible, there are
none that are available.
So we're out.
Is it any secret to any of
us that we're out of names?
Finding names is awfully hard.
Anyway, I guess the
good thing to know
is that we've known this problem
was important for a long time.
There's an organization called
ICANN, the internet Corporation
for Assigned Names and
Numbers, whose mandate it
is in part to worry about
naming on the internet.
And they've been worried
about this problem since 2000.
And in fact, in 2000
and then in 2004,
ICANN created a
handful, a total of 15,
new generic top-level domains.
But whether, considered
as experiments,
those worked or didn't, I
don't think they really changed
the naming crisis that
we have on the internet.
I'd imagine all of
you would agree.
So in 2011, as you can
see here in this picture,
ICANN voted to open up the
top-level domain name space
and allow any applicant
to suggest and apply
for a new top-level domain.
And that has actually happened.
So over 1,400 new top-level
domain names have been approved
and are working their
way into the name space.
In fact, there have been
over a million registrations
in the new top-level
domains since ICANN
opened this program.
So the other important
thing to understand
is unlike those prior 15
new top-level domains,
there are tons of
important interests
that are invested in making
these new top-level domains
successful.
Companies, not just Google,
but lots of companies
that you've all heard about,
for whom top-level domains are
an incredibly important
part of their strategy.
And even cities, like New
York, London, and Berlin,
are getting into the
top-level domain business.
So it's really, really likely
that we're going to see,
incredibly likely,
it's a given, I think,
that we're going to see
new names on the internet.
And I think we'll be talking
to our children or our friends
children one day and laughing
about the days when there were
only seven top-level domains and
when finding a meaningful name
in .com was incredibly hard.
So anyway, when ICANN
created this program,
we, Google, decided
to get involved.
We care deeply
about the internet.
The web is incredibly
important to us.
And naming and location and
finding things on the web
is at the heart of what
we think our mission is.
So that was why we created a
new business, Google Registry.
Now let me tell you a little bit
about how this business works.
In the world of naming
there are three participants
in the naming business.
The first is a registry.
You can think of it as a
factory that creates and manages
top-level domains, but they're
kind of the top-level domain
factory.
Then there are registrars.
These are the storefronts,
the businesses
that sell second-level domains
from n-tuple domains made
by registries to the public.
And we call the public
registrants, in this case.
So registries create
top-level domains,
registrars sell names in
those top-level domains,
and registrants purchase
those top-level domains.
And as I said, Google last
year launched a new business,
Google Registry, which is built
on App Engine, by the way.
We run on the Google
Cloud Platform.
And it provides
the infrastructure
for powering our
top-level domains.
And in fact, as part
of that ICANN process,
we applied for about 100
new top-level domains.
And these top-level
domains, as you
can see if you look at
the list on the screen,
reflect a variety of
potential business models
that we think are
going to emerge
in the world of this new
top-level domain name space.
So we have a bunch
of cases of things
that are Google brands
or Google products,
and you can clearly understand
what their relationship is
to us and why we might do them.
And then all the way
on the other extreme,
from things like
Android, and Chrome,
and .google as
top-level domains,
all the way on
the other extreme,
we have things like
.dad or .lol or .meme.
More whimsical
things where we're
looking at other ways of
using domain names to light up
entirely new ways of
interacting with the internet.
Now as it turns out,
other applicants,
there are other parties
who are interested in some
of these top-level domains.
Google may not end up in
possession of all of these,
but this was our intent.
And this is where we started.
So not only did we
think it was important
as the DNS name space, as the
top-level domain name space was
expanding, did we think
it was important to create
a registry in new
top-level domains,
but it made us think hard
about the experience of getting
online.
What it's always been
like, what it will be like,
what we would like
it to be like.
And we realized that that
moment of bringing your business
online, bringing yourself
online, acquiring a domain
name, managing a
domain, these are
incredibly important experiences
in the lives of our customers.
And we wanted Google
to be a part of that.
Not only that, we
wanted to make sure
that Google could provide an
experience to people buying
domain names that was a Google
experience, that was one where
we thought we could set
the bar for what the user
experience and the quality
of that experience would be.
And that was why we've launched
a new business, Google Domains,
which is a registrar which will
sell domains to the public,
to registrants.
And these are not just
new top-level domains
that we'll sell, not just
Google top-level domains, but as
many as possible.
The historic top-level domains
that we all know about,
and as many of the 1,400
new top-level domains that
are coming online
as we can sell.
So we think that
this registrar is
going to do a lot to help
us make the new names more
meaningful.
But let me tell you a little bit
about the other features that
are coming in the registrar
in Google Domains.
And I should point
out that we've
announced this as
a new business,
but we're not
feature complete yet.
We're in a limited
access beta period.
Soon I'll tell you how
to get a free code so you
can register a domain name,
or transfer an existing domain
name to Google domains.
But we're not feature complete.
We're still in beta.
It's invite only
beta, as I mentioned.
But here are some of
the things that we
think are important about
what our registrar does.
First of all, as I said,
it's a Google experience.
And I think it's one
that you'll recognize
the signposts of with relation
to other Google products.
Secondly, we want to make
things simple and transparent.
So for example, we're
not going to charge.
We're going to
build in the pricing
for private registration,
for example.
We're going to build
in all the features
that you expect in one
price for the domains
that you want to register.
We want to make it incredibly
easy to find a name that's
meaningful to you, and
we're using technology
from Google's
Knowledge Graph to help
you find domain names
in the top-level domains
that you care about, that
are meaningful to what
you're trying to search for.
So we're going to
help you find names
that you want to acquire,
help you acquire those names,
help you transfer names
in, help you manage them.
And if you want to,
we'll make it easy
for you to transfer
the names away
from us if you decide you
don't like us as a registrar.
We're going to give you
a live customer support.
During the beta period, that
support is 9:00 AM to 9:00 PM,
but you'll be able to actually
talk to a person to get answers
to any problems you have
with your registration.
And another thing that's
important to mention
is this is the
same infrastructure
that we use for
our own services.
So we think it sets
an incredibly high bar
for reliability,
security, and performance.
So we've also decided it was
really important to launch
with partners who can make
it really, really easy
for you to create
a great website.
And so many people want to get
on the web in the first place,
to create a website.
So we've done very,
very deep integration
with four partners, Shopify,
Squarespace, weebly, and Wix,
to give Google
Domain's customers
the option of easily working
with and using these companies'
products for the sites
that they're creating
through the domains they
purchase through Google
Domains, the registrar.
We worked really hard
to make the integration
of the registration experience
and the experience working
with the site builder
incredibly simple.
It's a really deep integration.
it's going to make it
really, really easy to use.
Of course, I should mention
that use of these companies'
products is available
at an additional cost
beyond that of acquiring
your domain name.
But, as I said, this is a beta.
It's an early invite only
beta and we've gone about
as far as we can
go by just testing
the registrar on our
colleagues and ourselves.
And this is why we're
moving to an invite
only beta period
because we want data.
Apologies to Brent Spiner.
I doubt he's in the
audience or watching us
on YouTube, but
Brent, apologies.
We want data.
We want your feedback
about the registrar.
I'll remind you once more, we're
still not feature complete,
but we really want to hear what
you think of this experience.
So, as I said, to
help you get started,
and feedback is so
important to us,
every Google I/O attendee
will get one free domain name
to acquire or to transfer
in into Google Domains.
You'll get an email soon with
more information about that.
I'll tell you more about
the email sign-up process
flow soon.
So we're really excited
to get your feedback
to help us make this
a great product.
Now kind of as a transition,
1,400 new top-level domains
are being created in
the world right now.
And although we're really
excited about what this means
for solving the problems
of domain name exhaustion,
or domain name space
exhaustion, unfortunately
there's an awful lot
of code out there
that is about to break
as a result of going
from a very small number
of top-level domains
to a very, very large
number of top-level domains.
And the person at Google who's
responsible for making sure
that we fix all the code that
breaks is Kripa Krishnan, who's
here to tell you
about what you need
to do to fix your
code that's going
to break as a result of this.
Kripa, over to you.
KRIPA KRISHNAN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Kripa.
I'm a technical program
manager at Google.
And I'm here to tell you about--
to worry about the concerns
that we have to face and the
issues that we have to face,
as hundreds of new TLDs
enter our internet ecosystem.
So let's just dive
in very quickly
and start looking through
a series of examples,
and we can see how this is
actually going to play out.
Taking a look at this
slide, there are three TLDs.
.foo, .photography,
and .minna in Japanese.
Nothing special about them,
except they're all new strings.
And hundreds more, if
I recall correctly,
close to 1,500
new TLDs are going
to be entering our ecosystem.
They are much longer than
some of our old strings.
We had a limited set
of TLDs in the past.
And if you look at the new
TLDs, the lengths of them
are quite unpredictable.
And they now come in a host
a brand new characters.
In the past, we had a very,
very ASCII, Roman character set,
very dominantly on the internet.
Now we have new character
sets from various languages
and scripts.
So just the fact that
you have new strings,
new lengths of strings,
and new characters,
lends itself to a host
of different issues
that we need to worry about.
So we're going to talk
about a few of these issues.
There's several
more to consider.
The point of my talk here
is not to just tell you
all the various
problems that we have.
I'd like to offer a few
fixes, but something
so you can take home with
you, and sort of consider
as you start designing your
applications if they're working
with URLs or email
addresses in general.
So let's start talking about
validation of new TLDs,
or TLDs in general.
Just a show of hands in the
audience, how many of you
have written any
code to validate
a URL or an email address?
How many of you believe
you got it right?
Wow.
That was a significant
drop of hands.
But the reason is,
it's complicated.
It's hard.
It's not a
straightforward problem.
And nobody builds a consistent
set of rules around this.
A lot of rules for
validation are hard-coded.
So it's very hard
for two applications
to actually do the same
thing on the internet.
So in our research, when we
were trying to find issues
with the way we validate code,
we found several such issues.
And I'll walk you through
a handful of them.
One of the issues
that we found was
validating based on
the length of a TLD.
For a very long time, when
we had a few dozen TLDs,
.museum was one of our longest
TLDs and it had just six
characters.
So a lot of validation
scripts around,
hey, if the TLD is longer than
six characters, reject it.
It's no longer valid.
So that obviously doesn't
work in the new world
because there are several
new TLDs coming about.
And we don't know if this
is the final wave of TLDs
coming about.
We don't know if ICANN will come
out and say, have a bunch more.
So this is not a usable
solution any more.
Another approach
people often use
is they create a white
list in their code.
And the white list
has a list of TLDs.
So if your application
is using TLDs
that are part of that hard-coded
white list, then great.
It all works.
Else it's rejected.
Well, this kind of might
have worked for a while
because the number of TLDs
we had was somewhat static.
Had a few dozen, so you
could hard-code a white list.
For a little while, it was OK.
But right now we're looking
at crazy refresh rates, right?
They're talking 1,500 new TLDs.
And so doing this sort of
white list creation thing
is impractical,
completely not feasible.
Probably time for us to
throw this technique out.
So this is not a great idea.
And finally, another
type of example
we've seen in hard-coding
validation rules,
is one where you check
for whether the TLD is
in ASCII characters.
It doesn't work
anymore because we
have 100 of the 1,500 new
top-level domains are all
going to be in various
languages and various scripts.
And this validation method
rejects several applications
that should be working.
So these are minor-ish in
terms of the problem space
I'm stating.
Why does this even matter?
Why is this even important?
Well, there's one reason.
On the internet,
your email address
is your primary identifier.
You can sign up
for a bank account
if you'd like, probably with
a user name and a password.
But if your account
is getting hijacked,
the bank needs to validate
your email letters correctly
and send you a note and
not a note to dev/null.
You need to know something's
going on with your account.
The Internet communicates
with you via email,
and if different
applications on the internet
are validating different email
addresses in different ways,
failing silently
in some cases, not
a great experience for the user.
So now what?
We get from what do we do
with respect to validation.
So do you actually need
to validate TLDs at all?
You might want to consider
if it's worthwhile
just not validating TLDs at all.
Treat them like SLDs,
allow any sort of values
to go through, unless there is
a solid reason for your product
to actually validate a TLD.
And these reasons do exist.
For example, if you take
the Chrome address bar,
Chrome actually likes
to pre-determine
whether a string that someone
puts into the address bar
is a URL or a search term, so
it can treat it accordingly.
So in this manner, yes,
validation is important.
And if you do have to
validate in such a case,
then use something
more authoritative
than a hard-coded list or
a hard-coded set of rules.
Authoritative sources could
be things like Mozilla Public
Suffix List, or you could
check against DNS, for example.
These are just
ideas for what you
could do with respect
to validation,
but it is worthwhile
considering whether or not
you actually need
to validate a TLD.
So we talked a little
bit of validation.
Validation pretty much
tells you whether or not
an end user can work with
your application or not.
So now I want to show you a set
of issues that confuse the end
user because you're surfacing
the problems with these TLDs
to an end user.
So we talk about a
handful of display issues.
So let me ask you
guys a question.
If you know the answer,
just raise your hands.
So if I were to
type www.example.com
in the body of something, in
the body of my Gmail message,
or if I type www.example.com,
press Space in a document,
what is the expected result?
Do you guys know what
is supposed to happen?
It's supposed to link, yeah?
Ideally, it's supposed to link.
In our own products, this
is what we found at Google.
Different products,
all of these URLs
in, I guess my left,
or right, whatever,
one of them, set of URLs
is absolutely correct.
And they're all valid, but
each application actually
figures out whether they
are TLD and auto-linkifies
in their own way.
So there's no consistency
even within our own products.
We found this to be
a very big issue.
It sounds pretty
silly right now,
but if you really
think about it,
a user copying and pasting
a URL from app to app
will have completely different
behaviors from app to app.
Seems small, but
we are working very
hard on trying to standardize
these sorts of things
and fixing this
within our products.
Let's take a slightly
more complicated example.
So in the case where your
top-level domains are
made of internationalized
characters,
we refer to them for the
purpose of this presentation
as internationalized
domain names.
Internationalized domain
names are domain names
where any part of
the domain name
has something of a
different script that
is not a Roman character.
I would like to dive
into a tiny bit of detail
as to how this actually
works, so we can talk to you
about the kinds of
problems this actually
surfaces to an end user.
In this example, in
the blue box you've
got a Russian domain name.
The Russian domain
name is human readable
and is encoded by an
encoding called Unicode.
However, the internet at
large, DNS specifically,
doesn't understand Unicode.
And it needs to translate this
Unicode into ASCII characters
for us to be able to move this
data through our DNS service.
So for this to happen, we
use encoding called Punycode
to translate between the Unicode
domain name and the ASCII
version.
What I'm really saying is that
the stuff in the blue box that
says Unicode and the stuff
in the yellow box that's says
ASCII both point to the
exact same location.
And the only reason
the ASCII version,
the xn dash dash
version exists, is
so that you can talk to
the rest of the internet
in the back end.
So what's the problem?
Here's an example.
Let's say I have a friend.
My friend's name
is Testing IDNs,
and my friend has a
Russian email address.
I put this person's address in
my address book in Contacts.
Looks great.
Everything's good.
Now I want to send
my friend an email.
So I say to Testing IDNs in the
To field, and if you notice,
the auto-complete over there
gives me the correct email
address for Testing IDNs,
except it translates it back
to the Punycode version.
So you'd see that it's the
exact same email address,
but now it has the
xn dash dash version.
So to most users, these
two are not the same.
This is a very
confusing experience.
Most people don't know if
they're doing a safe thing
or not.
This actually is quite sad.
And if you were noticing,
this is Google's Gmail
and Google's Contacts,
and we thought
this was highly embarrassing.
So we just went ahead
and we fixed it.
In the next few weeks,
you will actually
find this rolling out to all
of your inboxes eventually.
Anyway, so what
actually happened here?
Why are we surfacing this?
This is what we did.
We take this system that we
use to transcribe and move
stuff along the internet,
and present this ASCII
version directly to the users.
Simple fix.
Just make sure you translate
everything back to Unicode
at client level.
Every client upgrades to Unicode
when presenting information
to the end user, unless there
is an actual reason not to.
Yeah, just translate
everything to Unicode.
If you are paying
very close attention,
you might notice
that this actually
comes with it a problem.
And this is a
problem in security.
If I were to just show Unicode
characters to my end users,
we could end up with, just for
the purposes of an example,
something like this.
Do you see a difference
between www.google.com
and www.google.com?
These are actually
quite different,
even though they are
virtually indistinguishable
in certain fonts.
In a different font,
you could actually
see that the google.com
in the second row
actually has Greek characters
in place of other O's that we're
using in the first google.com.
So it is that easy to dupe
a user into using a site
that they believe they
are on when they're not.
This is not a new problem.
It exists today.
However, the scope of
it is much, much larger
with the large
number of new TLDs
and the large number
of IDNs we have.
Some products tend to
solve this by exposing
the Punycode version of
that, especially for IDNs.
They surface the Punycode
version to the user
because Punycode is a
fingerprint for every URL.
But to an end user, if you
show them a www.xn dash dash
sort of domain,
they are actually
feeling even more insecure
than they were a minute ago.
So this is not a great
experience either.
Unfortunately, we don't have
a great, simple one line
solution for this just yet.
We are experimenting
with a few things.
We are definitely
experimenting with things
like warning messages
to educate the user
if they are using character
sets or mixed character
sets that they may
not be aware of.
So at the moment we're
playing around with this,
but we don't have a
straightforward solution.
The point of this is
there are several others.
If you keep looking
under the hood,
there's several other issues.
How do you normalize TLDs?
How do you store TLDs?
How do you index them as
the environment changes?
And the point of
this is we really
need to take this into
consideration as you start
developing code where you
are using URLs or email
addresses primarily.
Now we also really want to help.
So in whatever way we
can, we'd like to help.
And to this end, we
have launched a new tool
in the last week or two.
We've been working very
hard towards this tool.
We've worked on a tool
that will help developers
use their applications
and validate TLDs
against their applications to
make sure that there's nothing
in their stack,
maybe UTF-8 issues,
if you're using a hard-coded
white list, whatever,
to surface these issues and
tell you how the TLD actually
interacts with your application.
This is not particularly new.
There are other such
examples that do exist.
However, the two big
differences between this
are we would like to
launch this tool on
pretty much every
new TLD if we can,
on as many new TLDs as
possible, and we would also
give you the ability to test
email with this same tool.
So let's just dive into it.
It's a simplistic thing.
So let's just walk through
it and see how this works.
The tool's called
Domain Test, and you
would find it on
several new TLDs.
For example, domaintest.foo,
domaintest.photography,
domaintest.minna.
The canonical source for
this is domaintest.foo.
We'll see a few more
examples in a little bit.
Let me walk you
through an example.
And for example, let's
use domaintest.minna.
So what I'm going to do is go
to the site domaintest.minna,
and Domain Test,
as a tool, supports
a whole host of HTTP commands.
If you look at this,
you will actually
notice that we support a
whole bunch of Echo and Stash
commands, so you can
use this for an example.
So in my Chrome browser,
I'm going to go ahead
and type domaintest.minna.
And I'm going to ask my tool
to echo back to me a string,
and the string over
here is, hello world.
So it's a browser, it
should technically work.
And if it works,
everything is good.
So here's what I get.
I get hello world
back from this URL.
Great.
Everything is dandy.
Now we need to see if
this would actually
work on a different
Google product.
So let's try something
with Google+.
So if I were to, by accident,
sign in to Ben's Google+
account and then
try to post as him.
And I want to see
if URLs actually
work in the link field
in this share box.
So what I would do is I would
take the exact same URL,
domaintest.minna, and
I'm trying to echo
the same thing, hello
world, back to me.
So what you'd notice is that
it would echo hello world back
to me, but you'd also
notice that it displays
the Punycode version
of domaintest.minna.
So you know there's a bug.
You go file it, and you've
got to try to get it fixed.
So this is sort
of how this would
work with your application.
The second thing that
we tried to do over here
is that this tool also has
a feature for email testing.
So this is something
that's a little new.
And here's how are
we're going to try
to test an email application
to see if this tool works.
Send an email to any
mailbox at domaintest.minna.
Again Domain Test
exists on several TLDs,
so I'm using domaintest.minna
for our example.
And I'm sending a note in
Gmail to say, test everything.
And if you notice,
many of you might
have complained
about this before,
but Gmail actually does not work
with internationalized domains.
So this was also
equally embarrassing.
So geez, we just went
ahead and fixed that, too.
So we'll show you an example of
what happens in a dev instance,
but in a few weeks, you will
see this roll out to all inboxes
where you will be able
to send and receive email
to all internationalized
domain names
and pretty much
any TLD there is.
In our dev instance,
this is how this works.
We would be sending a note to
a mailbox at domaintest.minna.
You will see that
the message got sent.
So you have validation
that the message got sent.
And you will also receive a
confirmation email in return
to show you that both your
incoming and outgoing email
have actually worked.
So this actually
works on Gmail today.
And that's pretty much it.
The great thing about this is as
soon as we launched this tool,
we tried to ask a few
registries if they would like
to host Domain Test in TLDs
that they were responsible for.
And here's what we got.
Within the last couple of
weeks actually, over 126,
or I think roughly
126 new TLDs now
have Domain Test
running on them.
Domaintest.foo is still
your canonical source,
thanks to Donuts,
Uniregistry, and AusRegistry,
and there are several
more on the way.
They're ready to actually
host Domain Test.
So you can go play
with this now.
It's live.
And if you have any
questions, there
are ways to get
to us from there.
And that's pretty much it.
From this point on, I'm
going to hand it back to Ben
to talk through the
potential that we
have the new TLDs going forward.
BEN FRIED: Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
So I wanted to talk just
for, so we kind of gave you
the big picture about lots
of new top-level domains.
Names on the internet are
never going to be the same.
We talked a bit about creating a
new registrar business and what
we think that means for the
experience of coming online.
Kripa talked about the bugs
this may introduce in your code
and what to do about it.
I wanted to end on hopefully the
high note of talking about what
we think our vision for what the
internet may be like with some
of these top-level domains.
And I'm going to do that
by talking about our plans
and tell you a bit
about what we're
planning to do with
some of those almost
100 top-level
domains that I put up
on a slide a few minutes ago.
So the very first top-level
domain that we launched,
and this actually went live
in December of last year,
is .minna.
Kripa mentioned it earlier.
Minna is the Japanese
word for everyone.
And what was important
for us about this
is that the top-level domain is
in hiragana, a Japanese script.
This was actually the
first top-level domain,
the first generic top-level
domain, in a Japanese script.
So it always struck
me as kind of strange
how Anglo-centric
the internet was,
that you have to understand
these strange abbreviations
of English language
words in order
to find sites meaningful to
you, even though you might not
speak English, or even
use a Roman alphabet.
And minna was important
to us because we
thought we could do an enormous
amount for the readability
of names on the
internet with it.
And this was obviously
just a starter.
As Kripa mentioned earlier,
there's going to be,
and if you looked at the
TLD list that I put up,
you'll see that there are going
to be domain names in Russian,
in Chinese, in
Japanese, in Hebrew,
in many languages
coming very soon.
So the internet is going to be
a lot more friendly to people
who don't use Roman scripts.
So thinking about what we
do next at Google with new
top-level domains, one of the
next top-level domains that
we're going to launch, we
haven't launched it yet,
is .soy.
And in this case, we're using
it to mean the Spanish word
for I am.
And what we want is to make
.soy be a top-level domain
for Latinos.
In America, Hispanics are
one of the fastest growing
groups in the
country, and our goal
is to make this
top-level domain be
known as a place
where there is content
particularly
meaningful to Latinos.
So we're going to work with
site creators and businesses,
content consumers,
content producers,
to create content
in .soy for Latinos.
But there are more things you
can do with top-level domains
than create meaningfulness
through readability.
And there are examples of
this that you're all already
familiar with.
If you think of .gov or .edu,
these are examples of top-level
domains where there are
restrictions to who can
register in those
top-level domains.
And those restrictions
actually provide a service
to the registrants in
those top-level domains
and provide a lot of
value to the users, people
visiting URLs and using
sites and interacting
with sites in these
top-level domains.
Obviously, if you
go to a .edu site,
you know it's an
institute of education.
If you go to a .gov site, you
know it must be a United States
based government
agency of some sort.
And with that same kind
of motivation in mind,
we are planning
on launching .esq.
Imagine a top-level domain
where every registrant
has been verified
to be a lawyer.
Imagine Jack
Donaghy.esq, for example,
would mean Jack
Donaghy the lawyer,
and not Jack Donaghy
the NBC executive,
if you want to go back to my
"30 Rock" example earlier.
We think this is going
to be really, really
helpful to people, to lawyers,
and helping them provide names
that provide more meaning,
but also obviously
to people who are using
these domains because
of the association that the
top-level domain will provide.
So we've talked about
using the top-level domain
to provide more meaning
in language, in script,
in restriction.
One of the other things
that we're planning on doing
is creating actual features
within the top-level domain
that provide special meaning
to the community of users.
One of the places
we're going to do this,
the first place we're going
to do this, is in .foo.
.foo is going to be a top-level
domain for people like you,
developers, people
who care about code.
We're planning on launching
features like requiring that
every site in .foo, there be
a well-known address that gets
you to the source code
repository for that site.
We're thinking about doing
things like making .foo provide
very, very simple Click to
Publish to a cloud hosting,
to a cloud hoster
features, for example.
These are things that we can do
by actually building features
into the top-level level domain
that didn't exist before,
and we think that we
can actually then create
new kinds of meaning for
important communities
with the top-level
domain in this way.
So that's just a hint
of what we're planning.
If I would go back to the
very beginning of the talk,
the thing that I think I'd
like you all to walk away with
is that we're
actually at the start
of a new phase in the internet.
Names on the internet are
never going to be the same.
They've only just
begun these new names,
so we don't really know how
it's all going to play out.
But we are going to
be there absolutely.
And I know that we're going
to look back in 10 years
and think about how different
the internet was in an era
when there were only a
handful of top-level domains.
So thanks for listening.
Oh, right!
Free domain registration.
I promised you all free domain
registration or a free domain
transfer.
On July 9th, expect an email
with an invitation code, which
you can use to get your
free domain registration
or transfer.
I should mention that Google
Domains, our registrar,
is only available in the US.
We're working on adding other
countries as quickly as we can.
There you have it.
And thank you very much.
We'll take Q&A.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
Are there questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I
have a question.
Is Google Domains going to
also do the DNS part or?
BEN FRIED: Yes.
So Google Domains hosts, yeah,
can host your DNS service.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it just going to
be a simple one or something
that's fully capable of handling
sub-domains and all that?
BEN FRIED: Yes.
It will be capable of
handling sub-domains.
We'll give you something
like 100 sub-domains
for free bundled in.
We'll also give you
domain redirects,
a whole bunch of other
features like that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Folks were really
excited or disappointed
with GoDaddy's response to
SOPA and all that good stuff,
and it's getting
really political
as domain ownership expands,
and now there's many more TLDs.
Has Google taken a
position how they're
going to deal with the political
environment for domains,
and censorship, and
stuff like that?
BEN FRIED: We don't
have any positions
we're ready to talk about
on those matters now.
AUDIENCE: I just
saw on your site
that you're providing domain
aliases, email aliases,
and forwarding it to Gmail.
So how does it work when I
want to mail with that alias?
There was no details on that.
Like say if I have my, say,
sandip@google.com-- that's
my name-- and you're
forwarding that mail to,
I think your personal
Gmail address.
BEN FRIED: Right.
And your question
is-- yes, that's
the intent of the feature.
AUDIENCE: How do I reply from
that alias domain name itself?
KRIPA KRISHNAN: I might
be answering this wrong.
If I am, please let me know.
I think you are looking to
send an email to any mailbox
for example, test@domaintest
dot whatever TLD you might want,
right?
AUDIENCE: No.
[INAUDIBLE] the description says
if I have sandip@google.com,
it gets forwarded to
your personal Gmail
address, whatever it is.
And then if I want to mail back
with sandip@google.com itself,
how do I do that?
COREY GOLDFEDER: In general, you
can set up domain email aliases
from Gmail.
As long as you can receive
email at the alias, it gets--
BEN FRIED: And yes.
And we're not restricting
that to just be Gmail, right?
But work with your mail
agent or your mail provider
to change the settings
to allow you to send
mail to come from that domain,
but each mail product generally
has ways of doing that.
It's specific to the product.
AUDIENCE: Maybe just a feedback.
Like if you can give
at least one Google
Apps ID with that,
that would have
been a much more better
way than making an alias
and making it complicated.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You seem
to be painting
a very rosy picture
about the domain names.
Do you have any concerns
about cybersquatting,
about people who were
going to be reserving
the exact same name
across 150, 200, 300 TLDs?
Because we're seeing that now.
It's not helping the
name exhaustion problem.
It's increasing the confusion,
and the common perception
is that the only people that
are benefiting from the new TLDs
are the registrars.
And you're a registrar.
BEN FRIED: Right.
So our registrar
and our registry
are separate business entities.
We're not doing this to
enrich one or the other.
I think we see a bunch of the
same problems that you see
and that you've pointed out.
And one of the
things that we think
is a great opportunity
with new top-level domains
is to create rules
that prevent a bunch
of the negative attributes
that have taken place
around top-level domains.
The specifics I think will vary
based on the top-level domain
and what we try to
do, but it's our hope
that there's an opportunity to
get a clean start here and try
to prevent some of the things
in the new top-level domains
that are accepted
practices in the old ones.
Since I didn't even see that
there's a line back there,
I'll take another question
from the back mic,
and then I'll move to
the group in front.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm wondering
about search engine
optimization.
So if I have a website
and it's website.com,
and I have resources for
programmers on that website,
website.com/programmers, that
programmers part of the site is
benefiting from website.com
being in existence for 10 years
in the search engine.
So if I follow the
practice you proposed
and make website.foo and move
my resources for programmers
there, how can I
guarantee that I'm still
going to get good
search engine rankings?
BEN FRIED: So gosh, I'm not
a search engine optimization
expert.
But I think at Google
we pride ourselves
on helping people find
things on the internet
and making search work.
And we're really
committed to making sure
that Google Search
works fantastically well
across the whole 1,400
new top-level domains that
are going to be coming out.
Beyond that, I can't kind of
offer you any more specifics.
I think we're all going
to see how this plays out
as these domains get
adopted and used.
But Google Search
isn't about favoring
one top-level domain
over the other.
It's about allowing people to
find things on the internet.
We hope that the new
top-level domains
makes those things
more memorable,
makes them more
meaningful, gives people
better naming choices.
We don't intend
to have that have
a negative effect
on searchabiity.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
COREY GOLDFEDER: Let me
chime in here for a second.
Also one thing we've
heard from other operators
of new top-level
domains, is that they're
recommending people in
your exact situation
to use the new
domain as a redirect.
So you get the name
space advantages,
but you still have
your canonical source.
BEN FRIED: I mean,
if you're working
getting in new top-level domains
now, you're a bit of a pioneer.
And I think in a
matter of years,
we'll all look back and realize,
oh, that was a great practice,
and that was something
that maybe didn't work out
so well, and so on.
These are early days for
these new top-level domains.
In 1985, and some of us I don't
think were even alive in 1985,
but in 1985, who could have
predicted that .com would be
essentially all used up, right?
Sir?
AUDIENCE: So are
you guys predicting
there's going to
be a huge adoption
rate with the new
top-level domains?
Because I notice even
in the existing market,
well, let's leave out
the 1,500 for now,
people will often
consider having
a name, foo.com,
foo.net, and they'll
think about food.biz, foo.org.
But anything besides
that, they're just,
I'm going to think
of a new name.
Do you think this
is something that's
going to change within
the next five years,
or are we looking at
adoption hopefully within 20?
BEN FRIED: I'm not a guy who's
good at predicting the future.
I wouldn't.
Don't ask me for stock market
tips or things like that.
I want to turn the question
around a little bit
and say that what happens with
these new top-level domains
is dependent on people like
you, who create sites, who
build apps, who through
the work that you do guide
how people use the internet.
No one actually knows what, or
when, or how this will take up.
I think there's a huge
qualitative difference
between the 1,400, 1,500 new
top-level domains and the 15
that were added to the
gTLD pool in 2000, 2004.
You can't even compare them
as being similar, right?
So I wouldn't want to make any
kind of predictions about time
frames, but I do think that
people like you and people
like us will be doing an
awful lot to try to figure out
how to make these as
meaningful as possible.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Could you ask another
question on to that?
Is Google Domains,
or Google as itself,
going to do anything to
accelerate every country having
a ccTLD?
BEN FRIED: We have
no specific plans
around that as an objective now.
Google Domains is still in beta.
We're really focused now on
completing our feature set
and going to GA as we
get feedback from you
all over the next
several months.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Question about privacy service.
Do you provide that only in the
US or for everybody outside?
And if somebody comes
from, say Utopia,
and is going to abuse a domain
that has privacy from you
on it, what will you
do with such a domain?
COREY GOLDFEDER: So privacy
is at the WHOIS level,
so that's definitely
any privacy [INAUDIBLE].
That's a question
for Google Domains.
I'm not from the registry team.
But I can tell you
that at the registry,
privacy is global
at the WHOIS level.
Generally, abuse is
also a registry issue.
There are abuse stopping
ways of going to a registry
and saying that a
domain is abusive.
And we support, for our
TLDs, the standard ones.
And if you had an abusive
domain on any other TLD,
you would go to the registry
for that TLD for that purpose.
AUDIENCE: So that means
that Google Domains
is going to other
registries to ask
to take these domain names down?
BEN FRIED: It's
a great question.
It's one that we're not prepared
to fully answer right now.
Brent, do you have
any-- so Brent,
who manages the team that
built Google Domains, is here.
Do you have something to add?
I have a mic here
for you if you--
BRENT: So thank
you all for coming.
So on a WHOIS, it will
work for all countries.
It's provided by a
partner that does it
actually out of New Zealand.
So it's not a service
that's going to be US only.
And then about abuse.
Abuse is handled
for every domain.
It's a requirement with ICANN
that we verify email address.
We do know that there's a way to
contact the owner of the site.
And that has to be
checked every single year,
so that we make sure that
that's always up to date.
If there's an
abusive situation, we
can always use then the
email to contact them.
You can inform us of abuse.
Every registrar has its own
abuse contact, either phone
number or email.
You can get that off the WHOIS.
You can also contact
the registries,
or you can contact ICANN.
Abuse is a big
problem, and we try
to make sure that
that doesn't happen.
So there's multiple
ways to handle that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Final question is, which ccTLDs
do you add on Google Domains?
Is there any?
BEN FRIED: No, why
don't you take it?
BRENT: OK.
So we're working to get
a number of ccTLDs out.
We currently only have two.
But we're working on increasing
that pretty significantly.
So I don't know which
ones we're actually
going to launch the GA with.
BEN FRIED: It's our goal to
support as many as possible.
There's only a few that
we've got right now,
but there's a lot of leg work
to sign up with more ccTLDs.
We're doing it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BEN FRIED: All right.
This it the last question
and then we have to move on.
AUDIENCE: You'd mentioned that
you're not good at forecasting,
but just one more
question around that line.
You see that right
now, everybody
understands any web address
to be just an address.
If it is a edu,
you just understand
that it is a university,
but it's still just a link
to go to a place
to look at content.
Obviously, with the stuff
that you're bringing
in, you're saying .foo will
be for developers and on top
of that, there is some added
features that's going to go
with it.
So it's kind of like
you're choosing your horses
in the game that might
pan out in the future.
So do you see that to be kind
of a fragmented version of what
things might be than
compared to right now, which
is just an address right now?
BEN FRIED: So I
think the goal is
to create new kinds of
meaning for a broad set
of constituencies.
Meaning specific to those
constituencies for them
in ways that the internet
never was able to do before.
You know what I'd like to see
happen with .foo, for example,
is I'm imagining a top-level
domain where people post
their hobby projects,
for example.
Or are companies that are all
open source in their software
development
practices, use those.
And you immediately
know, oh, .foo.
if I'm curious about
how that website works,
there's a well known
URL that I could
go to to find their
source code repository.
And there are things like
this that exist today.
People think about how they
use existing source code
repositories, for example.
Or how important it is for
some classes of developers
to post links to
their source code.
I think that in
the case of .foo,
I think we can do all sorts of
things where we accelerate that
and we create kind of new
features and new meaning
and new value for people in the
top-level domain name itself
that they were only able
to achieve otherwise.
And I think it kind of all
will come together for them
through those top-level domains.
So maybe, hopefully in a few
years, you say, oh, a .foo URL.
I know that's posted by
someone who cares about code
and who cares that
other people be
able to see how they
built their website,
or how they built their
app, and how the code works.
I think that there will
probably, hopefully
be a lot more of that on the
internet in several years.
That's certainly our hope.
I don't know if
that-- that's the best
I can do to answer
your question.
We have to end now.
The next team is coming
in for their talk.
So thank you all very much.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]